dear colleagues this morning
we have
the pleasure of welcoming t-shock
mir hall martin the irish prime minister
tishok thank you for
coming to address the european
parliament as part
of our this is europe debates this year
is an important one for ireland uh in
europe and an important one for europe
with ireland it marks
50 years since the irish people voted
overwhelmingly in favor of joining the
what was then called the european
economic community and 50 years on we
are pleased that irish citizens support
for the european project remains
extremely high
the irish prime minister being here with
us in plenary is also an expression of
ireland's commitment
as europe faces difficult times with an
illegal and unprovoked invasion of
ukraine
over the years the european single
market has helped ireland's economy
become highly competitive but ireland
continues to give a lot back to europe
too economically politically
and socially
economically ireland's success story has
allowed it to move from net recipient to
net contributor to the eu budget and
politically ireland plays a central role
in shaping common policies particularly
on finance
on the environment and on providing
vital aid to ukraine and here i must
commend ireland for being the first
country in the european union to waive
visa requirements for ukrainians and for
welcoming nearly 30 000 displaced
ukrainians who have sought
shelter
we are all painfully aware that ireland
is particularly affected by brexit and
good relations with the united kingdom
remain
in all our interests especially in this
new geopolitical context
on northern ireland all the european
union institutions are aligned
renegotiating the protocol on northern
ireland is not an option
the european parliament has reiterated
its unwavering supports for the protocol
on several occasions and we remain fully
committed to preserving the peace on the
island of ireland
last night this parliament officially
took receipt of a gift from the irish
government of a bust of former member of
the european parliament and nobel peace
prize laureate john hume
his legacy is an inspiration with
regards to conflict resolution and with
regards to respecting differences his
work in brokering peace on the island of
ireland and in hammering out the good
friday agreement is highly respected and
honored in this house
this parliament is attached to
multilingualism and with the irish
language now a fully fledged official eu
language let me say in irish goref magat
thank you
[Applause]
president um
vice presidents distinguished leaders of
the political groups
members of parliament
citizens of europe it's an honor to be
here today and i thank you president
masoli for your kind invitation to
address this session
i would like to salute your leadership
of the european parliament
before i reflect on ireland's european
path
it would be remiss of me
not to pause to pay tribute to that
great european david sacerly who graced
the office of president of this
parliament with such intelligence and
dignity
through his life
and in his work he demonstrated
integrity compassion
and a strong focus on the most
vulnerable in society
he will be long remembered especially
here in this parliament and he is sorely
missed
may you rest in peace
measure this is a critical moment in the
history of europe and the union which we
all share
we face a series of fundamental
challenges
will the values of free democracies
prevail in the face of military and
other aggression
will we act together to protect hard-won
progress in our societies
do we have the ambition and urgency
required to achieve energy security and
tackle an existential climate crisis
do we have the strength to overcome the
many forces which seek to return us to
the days of destructive rivalry and
competition between the nations of
europe
my message to you today
is that we stand resolutely with all
those who shared the core values of
peace democracy and progress in europe
and we believe
that protecting these values demands a
strong european union
membership of this parliament
is testimony to the diversity of europe
our languages our cultures and our
histories
no two nations are the same
however we come together and in a spirit
of mutual respect we plan our way ahead
we debate it and we lay it out
i would like to warmly welcome the end
of the derogation with regard to the
status of irish in the european union
since the beginning of this year irish
is today an unequal footing with the
languages of the founders other founders
of the european union
it is an important step ahead and it
will strengthen the use
language community of irish
being transformative
we have seen an overwhelmingly positive
impact across all dimensions of our
society
last month we marked the 50th
anniversary of the decision of the irish
people to join what we now call the
european union
and for us there is simply no doubt this
membership has been an historic enabler
of sustained progress for ireland
the decision of the people of ireland to
support membership was overwhelming but
it was not achieved easily
in the then six existing member states
questions were asked if ireland then the
poorest country in europe was simply too
peripheral and too poor to be able to
survive in the european community
at home a coalition of forces used the
classic anti-europe tactics of claiming
that we would be swamped by a
neo-imperialist organization and would
lose our separate identity
however an overwhelming majority
rejected these arguments the irish
people instead chose the path of hope
and solidarity of cooperation and a
shared future
time and time again this decision has
been vindicated
one of the inspiring things about that
decision 50 years ago
is the role which was played by leaders
from our revolutionary generation those
who as young people had done so much to
win our independence against tremendous
odds
they did not see europe as a threat to
our sovereignty
but as an enabler of our sovereignty
they rejected the idea of nationalism as
a narrow and defensive concept
instead they believe nationalism should
be outward and forward-looking
and just as
they did we continue to be inspired by
the ideas contained in our proclamation
of independence from 1916 when the
greatest of our leaders committed their
country to the ideals of equality
diversity and cooperation with other
nations
and that is why the democratic majority
of the irish people remain euro positive
and why we see the success of the
european union as directly linked to the
success of nation states
over the last 50 years sharing our
sovereignty with our european partners
helped to make us all safer stronger and
more prosperous
and ireland has in turn been proud to
contribute strongly to the shaping of
today's european union
in the intense debates and negotiations
of the past two years i and my
government have been very clear the
union must be strengthened
in order to serve us all better and to
respond to urgent challenges it needs
more ambition and resources we have been
and we remain supportive of a growing
and diverse union based on shared values
and shared prosperity
this has been a consistent theme during
our presidencies of the council
during our 1990 presidency we strongly
supported european union recognition of
german reunification
during our 2004 presidency we worked to
ease the arrival of 10 new member states
to our union and hosted a day of
welcomes to underpin this
through enlargement we have welcomed new
communities and they have since made a
wonderful contribution to the irish
economy and society
and enlargement has been essential to
strengthening the our union as a whole
as we are seeing every day during the
response to russia's war against ukraine
member states that secured their freedom
from soviet imperialism and
totalitarianism are a powerful voice
reminding us that free democracy must be
defended
i am strongly of the view that the
prospect of membership can be a powerful
driver of reform and that membership
itself is the most powerful tool we
possess
to enlarge the sphere of democracy peace
and security in our region
our treaties are clear that any european
state which respects the values of the
union and is committed to promoting them
may apply to become a member of the
union
it should be a source of pride and
inspiration
that the union continues to be a beacon
of hope to people at our borders
to the people of the western balkans to
the people of ukraine
currently sacrificing and enduring so
much in defense of our shared european
values to the people of moldova and of
georgia
we should support those looking to join
in undertaking the reforms and
preparations necessary
and when they meet the criteria we
should not place further barriers in
their way
i strongly support
i strongly support ukraine's application
for membership and i look forward to the
commission's opinion
i hope that when the european council
meets in june it will be possible to
send the people of ukraine a clear and
positive message
ireland
ireland's lived experience and we are
not alone in this
is that european union membership is
transformative
it is not it is not only about access to
markets and to economic opportunity
though that is of course important
it is about what it means to people
people who send their representatives to
this parliament
people
young people especially who benefit from
the freedom to move throughout the union
to learn to work to experience life in
another place and with another culture
people who gain confidence and strength
from knowing that they live in a union
of values of laws of democracy in which
human rights and human dignity are
fundamental guarantees
that is our strength
and ireland is proud to be part of such
a union
and no matter what its opponents say
let us never forget that the european
union is the most successful initiative
for peace in our continent's history
in ireland we feel this so deeply
because of the union's role in
supporting our successful efforts to
bring an end to campaigns of violence
which lasted for three decades when i
arrived in strasbourg yesterday i was
privileged to join president mitsola in
a ceremony to honor the only person to
serve as an mep who was also awarded the
nobel peace prize
john hume was a political joint
a proud irish nationalist and democrat
he dedicated his life to the cause of
serving his people and persuading the
minority to abandon violence and join in
democratic politics john was passionate
about his country's future and that is
why he was also a passionate supporter
of the european union
john had the vision to see the narrative
of ireland's path to peace in the wider
narrative of peace in europe
a peace built on respect for political
and cultural diversity cemented with
economic interdependence
he overcame opposition from both
extremes to chart a peaceful way forward
for ireland
his integrity and bravery shone through
with another courageous politician david
trimble he was awarded the nobel prize
for an unwavering commitment to peace
he won every election he stood in and
served in this parliament for 25 years
and it is one of the many harsh
realities of the brexit vote of 2016
that no serious consideration was given
to the implications for northern ireland
and the agreement which underpins peace
and reconciliation
the good friday agreement provides a
clear framework for protecting different
identities and interests in northern
ireland
it is a triumph for democratic politics
and it has been a model for conflict
resolution in many parts of the world
i can think of no more solemn agreement
than one which has ended a deadly
conflict
has been democratically ratified and has
been in operation for a quarter of a
century
because of this
a very detailed deal was negotiated and
adopted to limit the damage in northern
ireland caused by brexit
central to achieving this general gen
this generous deal was the unwavering
support and solidarity of our partners
in the european union including the
members of this parliament
i want to pay tribute to the european
parliament which was absolutely clear in
its support for the good friday
agreement and on the need to find a
unique solution that would work for
northern ireland
that solidarity mattered
that solidarity continues to matter
the unique solution was of course the
protocol in ireland and northern ireland
that is an integral part of the
withdrawal agreement between the
european union and the united kingdom
it is perfectly reasonable to look for
ways to improve the operation of the
protocol
but unfortunately what we have seen are
bad faith efforts to undermine a treaty
freely entered into
instead of trying to create a
constructive atmosphere for all to
engage we have actually seen efforts to
block agreements or introduce new
problems
in contrast the european union has
worked hard to find ways to ensure that
where there's a negative impact on
businesses and citizens in northern
ireland it is minimized as much as
possible
vice president of the commission
maharashtrikovic and his team have done
remarkable work in listening to
businesses and communities throughout
northern ireland
they have a deep and practical
understanding of the operation of the
protocol
last october the commission proposed a
package of measures that would result in
a significant reduction in border linked
checks
this parliament has also been incredibly
constructive for example in april you
overwhelmingly approve legislation to
help safeguard the supply of medicines
for northern ireland
i have said many times that that there
are solutions to practical problems
under the protocol if there is a
political will to find them
but that requires partnership
it requires the united kingdom
government to engage with good faith
seriousness and commitment
unilateral action to set aside a solemn
agreement would be deeply damaging
it would mark a historic low point
signaling a disregard for essential
principles of laws which are the
foundation of international relations
and
and it would quite literally be to the
benefit of absolutely no one
without a spirit of partnership
there would have been no peace process
in northern ireland without trust
without engagement
without a willingness to see things from
the point of view of others there would
have been no good friday agreement
no quarter century of peace in northern
ireland in which young people have been
able to grow and to flourish as
themselves
all of us in positions of leadership
owed to them
not to treat lightly what was so hard
won
as we look across our continent
as we see what is at stake when the rule
of international law is threatened it
falls to all of us to work together and
to stand by what we have agreed
i am humbled and inspired by the
extraordinary courage and resolve of the
people of ukraine as they defend their
country
and their right to determine their own
future
the conflict is at its most fundamental
about two utterly incompatible views of
the world
autocratic and democratic
the new imperialism of putin's regime
must not stand
ukraine's cause must be the cause of
every person who believes in free
democracy
as the european council said once again
last week
russia must end its slaughter and
withdrawal from the entire territory of
ukraine
i know that the speaker of the ukrainian
parliament mr ruslan stephan chuck is
here in strasbourg today
and to him i say
ireland unequivocally supports your
country your people and your right to a
peaceful democratic and prosperous
future
we
we strongly support the toughest
possible sanctions and we do so
understanding that this involves costs
for us all
we are honored that more than thirty
four thousand ukrainians have shot have
sought shelter in our country
how many times have we heard either logs
from the extremes condemn and attack the
the european union
yet today
for many millions of people on our
borders it is the flag of blue with a
circle of gold and stars which
symbolizes their wish to be free
in 2014
the people of ukraine took to the
streets to demand a democratic and
european future and for this they
suffered invasion and partition
we did too little to stand with the
people of ukraine then
we did too little to reject putin's new
imperialism and his demand to control
other countries in a sphere of influence
and this happened while he was
constantly investing
in extremist parties and disinformation
in our countries putting us all on
notice that the destruction of the
european union was a core policy
objective for him
we must stand with ukraine not just
during this war but in the months and
years ahead
our agenda must be ukraine's
reconstruction its securing of democracy
and its inclusion within our union
we must also support the democratic
rights of the russian people to new free
and fair elections
we must cont condemn the detention of
political prisoners such as sergey t
kanoskai the husband of the inspiring
leader svita lana
as a country with our own experience of
famine we condemn the illegal
appropriation of agricultural production
in ukraine which is having a direct
impact on global food security and
affordability and is affecting the most
vulnerable communities and parts of
africa and in the middle east
it is hard to comprehend
that hunger itself has been weaponized
ireland will support the european union
in playing its part in an effective and
swift international coordination to
ensure a comprehensive global food
security response
and just as as we are now showing
urgency concerning russian aggression we
also need to show more urgency on the
other major challenges facing our union
and our citizens
we must redouble efforts to accelerate
the decarbonization of our society break
our dependence on fossil fuels and
provide a more resilient secure and
sustainable energy system for future
generations
there are many who continue to ignore or
casually dismiss the scientific
consensus about climate change
however nobody can surely ignore the
direct political and economic threat
which dependence on fossil fuels poses
as far as ireland is concerned we
unequivocally accept that climate change
is a critical threat and it must be a
defining issue for us
an immediate and large-scale reduction
in greenhouse gas emissions is crucial
unless we act now terrible outcomes will
be inevitable we believe that europe
must push forward with its initiatives
including the european green deal and
the sustainable finance agenda
ireland is ready to play our part we
have enacted legislation to put a
legally binding target of reducing
emissions by 2030 to 51 below 2018
levels
in taking the necessary steps we must
bring our citizens with us and ensure a
just transition for all
let us make sure that the regions which
are most affected get a genuine
opportunity to transition to a
longer-term more secure and more
prosperous prosperous role in energy
production
i remain confident that we can rise to
this challenge
in this i am inspired by how we came
together in the face of the largest
pandemic the world has experienced in a
century despite the unprecedented nature
of covert 19 and after some initially
hesitant steps the european union
quickly came together in an
unprecedented way in support of its
citizens businesses and member countries
making it a role model for the world we
played a pivotal role in supporting
vaccine development and procurement
becoming the leader internationally in
the production and distribution of
vaccines
through next generation european union
the member states and institutions came
together in solidarity to address the
economic impacts of the pandemic across
our union supporting not just our
collective recovery but the green and
digital transitions we need to bring
resilience to our economies and our
societies
there are hundreds of thousands of
people alive today because of how we
worked together to understand control
and target this terrible virus however
there is no question that we were not
fully prepared for the pandemic and we
had to innovate new policies rapidly our
shared public health tracking and advice
structures were not strong enough
because we had not viewed this as a
priority area
and this is one of the many areas we
should address as we look to reforming
and strengthening the union
the european union is by no means
perfect
it is a project that must continue to
develop and evolve
and differences will arise between
member states between the institutions
however it is our capacity to work
together through these issues that makes
the european union something to be
immensely proud of
over the past two years i have signaled
at the council that ireland supports
more ambition and urgency in developing
the union
we have rejected the idea that every
debate must be a zero-sum fight between
countries
and that is why even though we are a net
contributor we supported a larger budget
for the union
the highly limited level of the budget
means that the union is often over
focused on a limited range of current or
desired powers at the expense of a more
active agenda of enabling activity
we believe that we need more investment
in skills and research the foundations
for sustained prosperity for all our
people
we have supported greater ambition on
key reforms to fully address the policy
gaps which caused so much damage during
the financial crisis
we believe that the conference on the
future of europe has begun an important
dialogue on our shared future
the recommendations of the conference
include some very worthwhile suggestions
that can be implemented quite quickly as
well as some that are more ambitious and
wide-ranging
let's focus on building a union which
can directly enable action in critical
areas and by respecting important
principles such as subsidiarity we can
have a more constructive debate
our guiding principle should be how can
we best prepare our union to continue to
meet the needs of its citizens into the
future
ireland is ready for this debate we will
work to constructively shape our new
future and are open to treaty change if
this proves necessary we should first
however do what we can within the
existing framework
we have in recent months and years
started to face up to the reality of
challenges to the core founding
principles of the our union
and this is not just an economic block
the treaties which we have all signed up
open up great opportunities for us all
but they also carry fundamental
responsibilities
the union cannot work if its members
refuse to follow the laws which apply to
us all
and the union cannot have a purpose if
we do not absolutely insist on
protecting democratic and human rights
in all of our countries
as john hume said
the basis of peace and stability in any
society has to be the fullest respect
for the human rights of all its people
for some time we've been going through
what has been called a democratic
recession in the world
there has been an attempt to push back
against the idea that democracy and
human rights are fundamental to
sustained human progress
every day we are seeing the terrible
human price paid when a country's
leadership stops debate
closes down political competition
controls the economy and ends the rule
of law
so as we learn the lessons of this
moment
let's understand that if we want the
values of a free democratic and
prosperous europe to survive and succeed
we have to speak up for these values and
we have to do so even when it's
uncomfortable
jean monet famously said
that europe will be forged in crisis and
will be to some of the solutions adopted
for those crises
he has repeatedly been proven right
however he missed an important extra
element yes we have constantly required
a crisis in order to make major changes
but ultimately we are more and more
seeing
that if we want progress for europe it
must be forged by its commitment to
values
we must protect and strengthen these
values
if we do this we will we will remain a
beacon of hope to others especially our
fellow europeans in ukraine
in our union we are better together
in our union we are better together
we are stronger together
we achieve most and best when we work
together thank you very much indeed
thank you
thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much
dear t shock for that inspiring speech i
now give the flow to the representatives
of the political group starting with the
epp group francis fitzgerald
president mazzolo commissioners
colleagues
tshop
thank you so much for so passionately
and comprehensively
outlining the importance of the eu to
ireland past present and future
as we both know membership of the
european union has been nothing short of
life-changing for the people of ireland
over the last 50 years
that historic vote in may 1972 to join
the european communities
changed the economic and social
trajectory of the irish state for the
better and as an irish woman i can
unequivocally vouch for this positive
change
the five decades have witnessed
ireland's emergence as a modern open
economy and society
shaped by close reciprocal cooperation
with our european partners
we strongly endorse the european values
of human rights democracy freedom of the
press and rule of law
the european union is a beacon a model
and an instrument for obtaining peace
fittingly last night as the thieshik
said we paid tribute to a committed
european a peacemaker and a former
member of this parliament john hume
we remember his outstanding work for
peace
and his
determined stance
against the use of violence in ireland
he believed in and personified this
institution describing the eu as the
most successful peace project in history
he believed in extensive dialogue to
bring about peace
that approach is a hallmark of the eu's
efforts to resolve outstanding concerns
within the protocol in northern ireland
the european way is to negotiate in good
faith
and we expect the same in return from
the uk not bad faith
pishuk you were right when you said it
would be a historic low to break an
international treaty i also paid tribute
to the commissioners mauro sekwe and
before him michelle barnier for their
efforts to resolve these issues they
have shown endless patience and resolve
and i want to take this opportunity to
thank my fellow parliamentarians here in
this house
for their understanding their deep
understanding of the consequences of
brexit and for their unwavering support
for ireland as a small member state
the brutal russian aggression and
invasion of ukraine illustrates the
scale of the threat to multilateralism
to human decency and the international
rule of law all member states have a
role to play in the future of defense
and security policy we must support one
another
i believe that the future of ukraine and
other eastern partners is within the eu
but i ask
is it good enough to say that your
future lies in europe
but that could be a generation away
the issues facing ireland today are
merged across europe ireland's
challenges are europe's challenges and
europe's opportunities are ireland's
opportunities ireland and the eu must
continue to defend democracy and the
people of ukraine we must come respond
comprehensively to the current
challenges of the the cost of living
crisis the energy crisis and work
together as we have done during covet
we are creating the future by the
decisions made here today and through
our engagement with our citizens
ireland's future is without doubt at the
heart of europe aaron gabriel and long
live europe gaurav mahagurt
thank you
very much francis
now on behalf of the snd group pedro
marcus
thank you madam president
mr mikhail martin tishak of ireland on
behalf of the socialists and democrats
and my leader iraq garcia perez i would
want to welcome you to the house of
european democracy
this parliament is very much concerned
about the position of the uk government
on the implementation of the northern
ireland protocol and its impact on the
republic of ireland on northern ireland
and on the uk and globally on the good
friday agreement so i would like to ask
you can you elaborate further on your
views on this matter
and let me take the opportunity of
having you here to address also a very
different but also complex topic tax
competition it endangers the so critical
collection of resources that you
referred to to shock
let me say clearly we welcome resoundly
the fact that republic of ireland joined
the oecd tax agreement on minimum
corporate taxation nevertheless as we
all know many other practices may still
be used to decrease real taxation
taxation
tishock do you agree that eu and the
member states
should cooperate more to level the
playing field on these matters thank you
so much for the opportunity welcome to
the european parliament
thank you very much mr marcus and now on
behalf of the renew group stefan sejuni
thank you madam president uh tishak
dear mikhail
thank you for your statements
allow me
on behalf of a very pro-european
movement in this parliament
uh to state that we're proud
of the irish government
we can very much count on ireland to
stand up for european unity
dear tishok the irish people can count
on renew europa and our members uh to
defend
their interests
for some time now
the interests
of the irish
match the interests of europe
and we look at the consequences of
brexit we all know
how worried
the irish and northern irish citizens
are
and
we're also worried about the uh food
security and the market
ireland's
dependence
on very much boris johnson's stability
and there's the irish protocol and the
irish including the northern irish
people who 56 percent voted in favor of
parties in favor of that agreement so
it's
not unilaterally up to westminster in
violation absolutely in breach of
international law to just do whatever
they feel like
based on their convenience and europe
having no say
supposedly
dear tishok
i will take advantage of the fact that i
have the floor to draw attention to a
very important point for our political
group the proposals to the citizens the
conference on the future of europe
we would make an appeal for a convention
so that if necessary we can allow our
treaties to evolve with the time
to
create the right of initiative
for the parliament and a number of
decision-making points unanimity on
certain points in the council for
example
a single state should no longer be able
to hold up
decisions of hundreds of millions of
europeans so
my question is what is the irish
government's position on these matters
and on this conference you answered in
part but
my political group would like you to
elaborate if you don't mind thank you
very much once again
longleaf europe along with ireland
messiah
[Applause]
now on behalf of the green group i call
philip lambert to take the floor
t-shock
welcome welcome to the european
parliament
actually when one looks at the history
of your country and history marred by
war occupation famine
poverty mass immigration a global
financial crisis which hit you like few
other countries
one might expect
a country of anger
bitterness
revenge
and we have none of that
none of that i'm really struck
every time and you embody that every
time i meet the irish colleagues
that we find
at the same time gravitas
but also a sense of optimism towards the
future and humility there's no
grandstanding it seems in your country
you don't need to grandstand to be great
and this is what i love so much
about the contribution that your people
are making to the european union and
being future oriented and optimist
to me comes out of your speech as well
again not with big words but let's take
one so sovereignty
instead of looking at this concept which
means the ability to decide on your
round
basically instead of looking back
towards the nation state you you and
these are your words you said the
european union is an enabler
of sovereignty it makes a small
sovereign country to what some in this
house are saying
but i like also and this is a change
from your predecessor and successor he
was also humble enough to recognize four
years ago that island was a laggard when
it comes to the climate transition and
it's true ireland was a laggard
but you embraced the new government and
indeed thanks to the participation of
the greens but your support your
personal support as t-shirt has embraced
the green transition now i do see the
great plans and the commitments
last year ireland's emissions grew by
six percent so we are still not there
there are still massive efforts to be
made but you and i see that the future
of europe's prosperity lies in leading
that transition rather than following
being laggards we need to be leaders
here if we want europe to be prosperous
a last point that i will make is tell
you that we will stand united and in
solidarity with ireland when it comes to
preserving the good friday agreement we
know that we are facing a british
government that we can't trust and i
think that even his own party well many
in his own party recognize that he's not
a trustworthy person uh but we have to
endure we have to endure and find ways
to keep peace in ireland and believers
we are with you on this thank you
thank you very much mr lamberts and now
on behalf of the id group marco zanigo
thank you very much indeed for joining
us here today because
in these times of
major difficulties one of the most
difficult moments faced by the european
institutions it's important to have an
ongoing inter-institutional dialogue
in particular between this parliament
and representatives of member states
first and foremost it's important to
ensure coordination and dialogue
to strengthen a point on which i believe
the european institutions have been a
little absent in these difficult times
and that's credibility
when a geopolitical challenge a major
one is faced as the one we are facing
now in the light of
russian aggression credibility is really
crucially important
unfortunately however due to strategic
errors
from the past
as we built our union and our model this
credibility this unity
have been somewhat lacking so it's
crucial that we should work together to
ensure that separate blocks are not
set up as sometimes we are seeing
emerging in
discussions on this emergency and we
have to think about
the why and how we can avoid these
mistakes in the future
decades of energy dependency on russian
on russia that was a political choice
actually taken in the past by the eu
that has undermined our position and
right now when today the parliament
should be voting one of the most
important provisions for the future term
we have to be very aware of our past
errors to avoid making them again in the
future
energy transition
and this commission has really focused
very heavily on that in this term
and the parliament has been working on
it for some time now it will not be
successful if it's um
led by uh ideologies and if we don't
learn from our past tying ourselves hand
and foot in times when we're trying to
shake off our links with russia tying
ourselves hand and foot to another
geopolitical situation china is not the
correct path to reshape the
socio-economic future of the european
union we therefore call on everyone to
think carefully about this and take the
correct strategic decision on our
autonomy on this package as well and let
me conclude on a final uh and further
important point we the european citizens
have made major efforts
to support
ukraine and its people in the face of
this aggression but for time for some
time now we've been calling for the
european institutions to take specific
steps because the burden of this
latest crisis to avoid it falling on the
shoulders of our people as well in the
face of the challenges we're facing
inflation high prices unemployment the
loss of purchasing power it's absolutely
crucial that there should be three
priorities for the european institutions
work work work we have a huge
opportunity to
shape our future model which has to be
based on an autonomy which will free us
from regimes and render us free in our
geopolitical choices if we are not able
to shape that system by learning from
the errors of the past unfortunately the
european union will remain weak and will
always depend on others thank you you
can count on us the ecr group charlie
famous
[Music]
one shooting a day one bombing a week in
areas ruled by criminal gangs and clans
called cost build
to name my country the most dangerous
country in europe
now i understand that your government is
pushing through
a mass amnesty
for how many no one seems to know
tishok
have you looked at
migration prognosis for the future
ipsys tells us that 1.5 billion people
would like to migrate if given the
opportunity the french government
estimates that 35 to 40 percent of those
would choose to europe
that's 500 million that would like to go
to our continent if given the
opportunity the same as the whole eu
population t-shock
africa's population is set to grow from
from 1.4 billion today to 4 billion at
the end of this century and there aren't
enough jobs
see shock martin
mass do you think that mass amnesties
for illegal migrants by eu member states
is going to alleviate or worsen
migration pressure on europe
thank you
i give the floor next on behalf of the
left group to chris mcmanus
thank you uh
president matsuola tishock in his final
speech to this parliament john hume
proposed that the eu should have not
available
i echoed these sentiments in the hope
that a similar approach underpins
ireland's council of your presidency
assumed recently for as we know human
rights are the core of the council of
europe
sometimes in this institution we let
economic considerations blind us to
human rights violations i refer
specifically to the british government
which daily shows its contempt for the
rule of law and in particular
international human rights law they are
announcing the european convention on
human rights and actively undermining
the good friday agreement not only are
the unilaterally rewriting the protocol
but also imposing one-sided legislation
on the legacy of the conflict providing
an amnesty for crimes committed by state
forces
the international community has and
needs to continue to defend the good
friday agreement
finally tashak could i remind you that
human rights often intertwine with
social and economic rights the rights of
ordinary people to a home must trump the
supposed rights of those who are pricing
people out of the housing market are
charging extortionate rents gourmet give
glare
thank you i give the floor next on
behalf of the non-attached members to
clear up on saturdays
thank you president
thanks for being here and for your
remarks
the fundamental rights of any european
must be the concern of every european
and in 1976
ireland lead by example you took the uk
to court for torturing detainees in
other languages it was an uphill fight
but time has shown that you were right
yet decades later we still see judges
using
evidence extracted
by mistreating
detainees
a recent ruling of the european court of
human rights ruled that a conviction to
17 years based on a confession extracted
in isolation and without counsel was not
a fair trial
the man was set free but last week the
spanish supreme court disobeyed and sent
him back to jail
spain's disregard for the
distress word court is astonishing 11
times have they been condemned for not
investigating churches but guess what
the judge that was blind to obvious
torture in six of these cases the
delinquent judge mr randa maraska is now
security minister in spain
toy shack the tolerance of eu
authorities to spanish human rights
violation is alarming
we urge you
to make your voice
and speak clearly about that
we need to hear ireland's voice again
please defend
human rights for all europeans thank you
very much
i give the floor now once again to tisha
martin to respond to the questions of
the group leaders
first of all could i thank all of the
members
for responding and for the points that
you've made and i think i remember uh
francis fitzgerald uh made i think a
number of key points not not least the
transformative impact again of european
union membership in ireland particularly
women
in ireland over the last um 50 years
and also i think you made a key point in
relation to enlargement
and i think you posed a question
if we said to countries that you you
know we want you to join our opening the
door why does it take so long
and my own view is that the enlargement
process has taken far too long
and i think we need to have a
fundamental
reflection on this
we're with the western balkans before
christmas last
there is no reason why north macedonia
and albania should not be members of the
european union now
and in my view we have to accelerate the
process we have to make a fundamental
call as a union
in terms of enlargement
ireland
my own personal view is coming from
where we're coming from ireland you know
1973
and
it has been transformative there's no
point in saying anything else and
because of that i always feel it very
difficult to put a barrier up against
another country that wishes to join that
fulfills the criteria that would be our
view we don't think politics should get
in the way
our localized or regionalized issues
should get in the way of a country being
allowed to join i think it's a key
question it's a fundamental point that
we should all um reflect on uh i think
the next issue was two point from i
think it's marquez
in relation to first of all the protocol
i know you asked me to elaborate i don't
think i have the time to elaborate fully
uh but what i would say is that uh
which if there was a nobel peace prize
for patience uh he would win it um hands
down and i want to thank him for the
role um that he has played
but to say that fundamentally where it's
at
is that
unionist politicians have raised
legitimate questions
you know issues around the operation of
the protocol
and we believe we can the european union
that is believes that it can resolve
these issues
but the fundamental question remains as
to what the british government's
ultimate position is and that's why i
refer to my opening address to the
absence of political will i just simply
do not detect a sustained political will
on behalf of the uk government to settle
this and resolve this because it without
question can be resolved
and the more fundamental concern i have
is on that overall stability of the
architecture of the good friday
agreement and the spirit that informs
that i said earlier you know that it
took a long a lot of work from a lot of
people to
get to good friday agreement over the
line
and therefore we should all be very very
careful in doing anything that could
undermine that and i feel the uk
government
is not giving due consideration
to the totality of what's involved in
the good fighter agreement
and on tax competition
again ireland was very um constructive
and cooperative in terms of the oecd
process and we signed up to that
as a country we continue to engage
at international level in all four
in relation to tax issue but the more
fundamental issue that we find now in
terms of foreign direct investment
coming into ireland is the talent
question
and most companies are in search of
talent or ability and so on
that speaks to the question of migration
that a colleague also spoke about and
questioned ireland's
uh
certainly that there was an amnesty in
ireland there's no amnesty in ireland
but we do believe that if the
undocumented
are
undocumented for a long period of time
they need to have their lives
regularized they need to have their
lives resolved and become full citizens
of ireland that's what we're doing
and just would make the point in terms
of the question around migration
the reason
president biden is president of the
united states
is because of an enormous migratory
trail from ireland to the united states
after the famine and throughout the 19th
century we are the last country
to start condemning migration
are to take a very
narrow perspective um on on migration
and that is our position on that and one
of the transformative things in ireland
today is the multiculturalism of modern
ireland that so many countries have come
from within europe our citizens have
come from within europe and beyond
europe to live in ireland uh and uh i
was taken by what philip said earlier
that there is that still that generosity
of spirit still in ireland
and that engagement and long may that
continue we have to work at that there
are always challenges
um around that and i take on board what
you the the nice comments you made in
terms of humility and
gravitas and so on
although the city i come from an ireland
people don't normally associate us with
humility or modesty but that's an
internal irish matter um but i do take
your point on climate change
it's about delivery now we have passed
the legislation i think what we have
done though is put the template in place
on the foundations for fundamental
change into the future the real
challenge is delivery and really getting
political consensus on delivery
and i'm passionately committed to this
and to the restoration of biodiversity
as well and we've a journey to travel
but we're committed to doing it and the
legal framework is in place and if i say
so offshore wind is will be a very big
development in ireland over the next
decade or so
and we're going you know we will be a
net exporter in the mid 2030s of energy
because of the fact that we have wind a
lot of wind around our coast which is
seven times the land mass um of of
ireland and in terms of uh i think
stephanie's point in terms of the
conference of the future for europe we
are very open and i'm very open to the
idea of treaty change on the basis of
the enlargement question if we enlarge
we have to
work out how we manage and operate the
union more efficiently and more
effectively uh we can't operate with old
rules as the as
as the union enlarges itself so we're
very much
in favor of of of really pursuing that
particular issue and being open to
change in terms of how we do things
within the council the parliament's
right to initiative and so forth
i would have a strong belief in public
health for example i was a former
minister for health
i witnessed how every domestic every
domain every national state oh can't
allow our health systems or whatever be
the competency to move to europe and so
on what we saw during the pandemic
public health now as a discipline within
the broader health arena
really is a european competency
the hera initiative and all of that is
essential to the future of public health
across europe uh when i was a minister
of health there was no chance of
procuring vaccines not a chance it was
so discordant and so forth to me was a
marvel to see europe procure
vaccines enable the production of
vaccines and become the largest donor of
vaccines in the world for which the
european union doesn't get credit
the largest donor and most consistent
owner of vaccines um across the european
union um
the
in terms of the um
the energy transition and i think zany
if i might have the names quick but the
point made in relation to the
geopolitical situation
ties to china i think the ukrainian
the war on ukraine is called causing us
all to reflect very deeply on how we
develop relationships into the future
how we maintain them in terms of the
rule of law values and democracy
and i think that's going to be a period
of further reflection in terms of how we
engage
with with others who also transgress the
fundamental values uh in our system i
think i've dealt with the migration
issue suffice to say that we need to
work much harder on climate change on a
whole range of issues
to reduce the necessity for migration
and to enable sustainability within many
countries in the neighborhood of europe
and in africa in terms of economic
sustainability social sustainability
climate sustainability that's ultimately
the way that we have a proper balanced
approach to these issues in relation to
chris mcmanus's point
in terms of
again i was at the council of europe
yesterday met with the secretary general
also visited the court uh the european
court of human rights which is a strong
resonance with ireland because of our
history and because of the work it did
um in terms of northern ireland also in
the erie case for example which is
fundamental in terms of access to legal
aid not just for ireland but for the
entirety of europe in terms of that
decision
and also the norris case and lgbtq
rights
and lisa keith case
also so we have a strong affinity with
that um and um
again what was interesting is the united
kingdom government have nothing to fear
from
uh the european court of human rights
in fact it has one of the lowest number
of cases against it it seems to be very
determined to create problems where
problems don't really exist
and so we're very committed to that
and again on a more general level in
terms of
tolerance of
any violation of human rights
we are very strong on human rights as a
country we want to be and we will
continue to play our part at european
union union level in advancing human
rights i want to thank you all very much
for for your contributions it's been a
privilege and an honor for me to address
you as teacher and i look forward to
engaging with you
in the time ahead thank you very much
indeed
thank you so much
[Applause]
thank you so much dear t-shock michael
martin for those comprehensive replies i
see
the reaction from the room is testament
to
the engagement of this parliament and
the ongoing discussion that we can have
with you and your country dear
colleagues the debate is closed
i have
a number of announcements to make before
we go on to the next item
uh in relation to the decisions by the
ita and econ committees to enter
into inter-institutional negotiations
pursuant to rule 71 paragraph 1
announced at the opening of the session
on monday the 6th of june i have
received no request for a vote in
parliament by members or political
groups